I have to give a little bit of credit to
will Thomas you know the guy who goes by
Leah he's the swimmer who beat all the
girls on the Penn swim team will Thomas
was just on some sort of podcast
and he explained how unreasonable it is
for conservatives to buy into parts of
transgenderism but then oppose men in
women's sports
they're like oh we respect Leah as a
woman as a trans woman or whatever we
respect our identity we just don't think
it's fair you can't really have that
that sort of half support where you're
like oh I respect you as a woman here
but not here they're using the guys of
feminism to sort of push transphobic
beliefs and I think a lot of people in
that camp sort of carry an implicit bias
against trans people but don't want to I
guess fully manifest or speak that out
and so they try to just play it off as
the sort of half support they think
about how twisted feminism quote unquote
feminism has become their arguments you
know in order to exclude anybody in the
trans category you have to reduce women
to reproductive capacity which is in my
opinion extremely anti-feminist I don't
want to put those women down either and
I know you don't want I don't want to
either because I see pain I see pain and
the pain is coming from somewhere it's
not you though it's the patriarchy and
how can we get people to see that
no I think it's you I think it's coming
from you and it's coming from people who
are invading their bathrooms and their
locker rooms and taking their trophies
and their scholarships that's where it's
coming from will is right this host of
the show is completely incoherent but
will Thomas is totally right
when he says it just doesn't make sense
you're gonna expect you're going to
respect me as a woman in certain parts
of society but not in others you're
going to go halfway you're going to tell
me that you know that I'm a woman but
you're going to behave as though you
know that I'm not a woman doesn't make
sense
doesn't make sense
will Thomas totally right
not only is he a great swimmer at least
when he's raising women but he's more
logical than just about anybody in the
transgender
movement
either transgenderism has to be
established in our law and in our
culture as activists are trying to do
right now they've been trying to do this
since 2020 so it's relatively recent but
in the Bostock decision from the Supreme
Court in Harris Funeral Home's decision
from the Supreme Court
the court has said we are going to
redefine legal protections on the basis
of sex and we're going to now say that
their protections on the basis of gender
identity which ironically undermines
protections on the basis of sex
if you have legal protections on the
basis of sex that says girls get their
own swim teams and then you redefine
that to say actually people who identify
as girls get their own swim teams then
what you've said is girls do not have
their own swim teams because will Thomas
is going to compete against you and take
your trophies
okay that's what our law has
increasingly been saying
we either need to follow that to its
full conclusion
or
for the good of society and especially
for the good of the poor people have
fallen prey to this confusion
transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life entirely the entire ideology
from top to bottom
those are the two options
will will Thomas and I are in agreement
on this subject if you disagree I don't
know you're disagreeing with the most
prominent spokesman of the transgender
movement and knuckle dragging
conservatives such as I right now go to
goodranchers.com use promo code at
Knowles if you have not changed the way
you buy meat yet you really need to do
you know what I had for dinner last
night
give you one guess I had good ranchers I
had a delicious good Rancher steak it
was juicy it was it's just it is the
finest quality beef that I have in my I
have it not every day but a great many
days I just adore good ranchers I got
three reasons for you one they give you
free bacon for a year that's a pound and
a half of bacon in every box 240 value
number two good ranchers offers a price
lock guarantee meaning that when you
subscribe your price does not change for
the length of your subscription meat is
expected to go up four and a half
percent in the coming year so this could
be a huge savings for you and your
family number three good ranchers meat
is unlike any other
all natural Burgers USDA prime steaks
better than organic chicken will change
your standard for great meat it's I'm a
real stickler when it comes to my meat
quality it's magnificent go to
goodranchors.com use promo code nulls
for 20 bucks off your box
free bacon great meat a secure price and
a bonus twenty dollars off today promo
code Knolls at goodranters.com
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
this is the most disturbing story I've
heard all week
out of the Netherlands
officials in the Netherlands have
approved assisted suicide for people
ages 1 to 12.
babies to pre-teens can now kill
themselves
legally and doctors can help them do it
they will permit the doctors to
euthanize children deemed to have
conditions which will lead to hopeless
and unbearable suffering
now the way that the Dutch officials are
describing it they say oh this is for a
very extreme cases people who are days
away from certain death and they're in
such intense pain that we're just going
to put them out of their misery now this
is not how euthanasia how assisted
suicide actually works in practice you
remember shortly after the Netherlands
approved assisted suicide some years ago
people warned this isn't going to be
only used in extreme cases this is going
to be used to put down people who the
the state deems Unworthy of life even
people who don't want to die and then
there is a very famous case of a woman
who did have dementia and so I guess she
had forgotten that she had authorized
this
assisted suicide and when the doc came
to poison her she she said no and the
doc said too bad I'm killing you anyway
and she said no no no and she fought
back she tried to push him away and then
her family held her down while the
doctor killed this woman
that's what it looks like and what it
looks like is incentivizing people who
are a little bit depressed who are a
little bit anxious who fear that they're
a burden to their families
incentivizes people to kill themselves
and now they're doing it for little kids
and everyone looks at this and they say
this is horrible this is shocking how
did this happen
this was always going to happen
it's the same people who look at
tranzing the kids and they say oh my
gosh this is shocking how did this
happen this was always going to happen
the minute you accept the logic of
assisted suicide of Youth and Asia Youth
and Asia which is called it's it's a
term that means good death but it's not
a good death it's the worst death of all
it's the death uh that it totally
expresses despair
the moment that we accepted that logic
that the perfect expression of Despair
is a good death
and was always going to
end up with the kids the moment that we
accepted the idea that you had some sort
of right to kill yourself that was
always going to go down to the kids just
as when we accepted the idea that a man
can secretly be a woman well then that
was always going to affect the kids
because if it's true if the transgender
anthropology is true then of course we
have to extend the transit procedures to
little kids it would be cruel not to If
there really it's really a girl trapped
in a boy's body then of course we've got
to put him on cross-sex hormones
certainly before puberty we've got to
make some interventions because
otherwise it'll be harder for him to
transition and express his true self
but it isn't true
and in the case of suicide you don't
have a right to kill yourself
there is no way to make a coherent
argument for the right so-called
to kill yourself
so it's just a pure imposition will you
say well I want to do it
and by the way we've got all these
people that I deem useless and valueless
so let's just get rid of them you know
they're just a drain on society and then
we get horrified when we see The Logical
consequences of that play out
boy was that good it was really
excellent incisive handsome commentary
if you want more of it you got to ring
the bell and click the thing and do the
doodad And subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel
see you next time
[Music]